[Music]
Hey,
hey, hey.
[Music]
Christian.
Hello. Before
we get into our regular flow for the
service though, we just want to take a
quick moment to acknowledge some amazing
volunteers who were with us all day up
here yesterday. Um, several of them got
here at 8 am and didn't leave until like
5:30. So, well, some of us didn't leave
till 6:30 actually now that I think
about it. So, anyways, it was a long
day, but it was such a fun day for our
kids, and it just meant the world for
those who showed up and gave of their
Saturday. And I just wanted to name them
for you. Um, not because they need it,
but because I need to say thank you from
the bottom of our hearts. Our kids team
is myself and Angie Cabillo and Oh,
Angie Cabalero. I've known her a long
time. Angela Rollins.
That was her maiden name when we were
kids. Um, and Kaylee Fischer, whose
husband Landon actually also um pitched
in. Mindy Reynolds was there. Brett
Tilford, Katie and Abby Salsman were
there. Charles Holly, um, let's see,
Eden, um, McDonald and, uh, Kelly
Tilford, and Nancy Pertie, and
I might have covered most of our adults,
and a slew of teens, Eve, August,
Harper, Chloe, all of you. I'm just so
Meyn, Maitlin, thank you. Thank you from
the bottom of our hearts. We're so
grateful. and we just wanted to give you
a little sneak peek into what summer is
like to wet your appetite so that next
year you guys can come out and join us
in the action. So enjoy this little
promo video and I will just do a little
call out to Justice Watts who helped
make the intro for this video. So enjoy.
[Music]
Set. Go. Ready.
Yeah.
[Music]
Heat.
summer. We're going to look at all the
galaxies.
[Music]
[Applause]
It's a nice.
[Music]
Hey,
this is good for me.
[Music]
Happy birthday.
[Applause]
Go summer.
All right. Hello everyone. My name is
Jonine Horton. She her. and I wanted to
welcome you and like you already have
been welcomed but I'll welcome you again
and especially all of you online folks.
Okay, I wanted to have one little
announcement here and that's to let you
know that if you're a little anxious
about being in a church setting or part
of the disability community or you just
feel fidgety today. We have an
accessibility bucket over here on the
table to my left. And there's noise
cancelling devices, fidgets, coloring
sheets. Uh we just ask that you return
them to the bucket at the end of the
service.
Okay. We have a celebration of the life
of Will Humble that you are invited to.
Uh this um will left us to go to the
Lord on June the 12th. July the 12th at
11:00 a.m. right here at First United
Methodist Church at Saxi
uh will be a celebration. So you're all
welcome. Uh in lie of the costly flower
arrangements, uh we request that you
make a donation generously to the
trevorpro.org
or to the children's college fund.
And no mourning at this one. We want to
wear our brightest, most celebratory
clothing to celebrate this gentleman's
life.
It's always fun when you have a surprise
announcement.
All right, everyone. And uh we light
these candles as a sign of the presence
of Christ among us, fully divine and
fully human.
And now if you'll just relax for a
little bit, take some deep breaths. We
are going to exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry, and productivity.
And we are going to enter the kingdom
of silence and stillness and simplicity.
A sacred space, a place for prayers and
worship and adoration,
a place to behold Christ.
Revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
Thanks, Janine. If you guys would stand
with us, we're going to begin our
worship. Y'all can follow Jesse and uh
you're welcome here. You are invited
into this space to worship alongside us.
So, please, if you know the songs, feel
free to sing out or soak them in. Um but
fill up this space as your own because
it belongs to all of us.
[Music]
Christ is my firm foundation.
the rock on which I stand. When
everything around me is shaking,
I've never been more glad that I put my
faith in Jesus
cuz he's never let me down. He's
faithful through generations.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
No, he won't. No, he won't.
I still got joy in chaos.
I've got peace that makes no sense. So I
won't be going under.
I'm not held by my own strength. Cuz I
built my life on Jesus
and he's never let me down. He's
faithful in every season.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
He won't fail.
[Music]
He won't.
He won't fail.
Christ is my firm foundation.
The rock on which I stand. When
everything around me is shaking,
I have been more than life that I put my
faith in Jesus
and he can never let me down. He's
faithful through generations.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
[Music]
He won't fail.
He was
[Music]
me down.
Seen rain came
my house was built on you. I'm safe. I'm
safe with you. I'm going to make it
through.
came in blue. My house was built on you.
I'm safe with you.
I'm going to make it through.
Make
my house built on you.
I'm safe with you.
I'm going to make it through.
Yeah, I'm going to make it through.
My house was built on you.
I'm going to make it through.
Cuz my house was built on you.
Cuz I'm standing strong on you.
I'm going to make it through.
My was built on you. You Christ is my
firm foundation.
[Music]
the rock on which I stand. When
everything around me is shen,
I'll never be more than that. But I put
my faith in Jesus
and he's a never bear me down. faithful
through generations.
So why would he
[Music]
fail?
He won't fail.
He won't.
[Music]
He won't fail.
He won't.
Amen.
kiddos, you guys are dismissed to go to
your classrooms. And if this is your
first time here, we have kids classes
available from sixth grade all the way
down to nursery. And if they want to
meet their teachers over here by the
doors, they will take them to the
appropriate classrooms. Um or you are of
course welcome to walk them there
yourself as well. Thank you, kids
ministry team so much for helping with
our kiddos and loving on them. You guys
are amazing and we're so grateful for
you.
And as they um head out to their
classrooms, we are going to transition
to what we call prayers of the people.
And this is um a tradition that's been
passed down through Christian history.
And it's an opportunity for us as a
community to lift up the things that we
carry into this space together and hold
them before Christ together. Um, so the
parts that are in red, we will read
aloud together and then there will be a
space in the middle for you to offer out
a um person or a situation that's on
your heart to speak that out and then
we'll wrap up the prayer at the end. So
you guys can just follow along on the
screens.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us, and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
and Alex
and Ash.
[Music]
For the names of the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have light and life,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence. Amen.
[Music]
out of control. I feel it losing money.
No, it's not easy letting go and
trusting you.
And if I'm being
honest, I know that you've said you got
it. No, it's not easy letting go and
trusting you.
So I will stop. So I will stop.
Breathe. Rest here in your goodness. I
know you only. It's my confidence. It's
my confidence. I will
bring rest here in your goodness. I know
you only. It's my confidence. It's my
confidence.
[Music]
Standing out of control. I feel it.
Losing my defenses.
No, it's not easy. Let's
go and trusting you.
Tiff being
honest. I know that though you said
you've got it. No, it's not easy. Let me
go and trusting you.
So I will stop and I will stop.
Breathe. Rest here in your goodness. I
know you won't leave. It's my
confidence. It's my confidence. I will
start
breathe rest here in your goodness. I
know you won't. It's my confidence. It's
my confidence.
I am in the palm of your hand. Nothing
can take me away.
Nothing can take me away.
Here I am in the palm of your hand.
Nothing can take me away. Nothing can
take me away.
Not a high or a death, not a lie inside
my head, not a fear or a fence. Nothing
can take me away.
Not a hide or a death, not a lie inside
my head. Not a fear or a fence. Nothing
can take me away. Let's sing that
together. Not a hide nor a dead, not a
lie inside my head, not a fear or a
fence, nothing can take me away. Oh, not
a hide or a d. Not a lie inside my head,
not a fear or a fence. Nothing can take
me away.
Nothing can take me away.
Nothing can take me away. Nothing can
take me away.
Nothing can take me away. Here I am.
Here I am in the palm of your hand.
Nothing can take me away. Nothing can
take me away. Here I am in the palm of
your hand. Nothing can take me away.
Nothing can take me away. It's my
confidence.
It's my confidence.
It's my confidence. It's my confidence.
Nothing can take me away.
[Music]
I'm reminded of that passage that says,
"Look at the birds of the field." I'm
sorry. The birds of the air,
they don't worry. Look at the liies of
the field. They don't worry.
Will your father not take more care of
you?
[Music]
And tonight,
I know each of us have our areas that
are hard to let go of,
the things that are hard to give over
and trust to God.
I pray that in our hearts as we sing the
words to this next song that we will be
be reminded that we are children of a
God who cares for us.
He loves us.
He is always good and we can trust him
with that.
[Music]
You meet me on the mountain top.
You see me in the valley low.
There is no home without you here.
[Music]
And I find you in the crowded thoughts.
You quiet all the question marks.
There is no space your love won't fill.
I'll trade all of my fear for peace of
mind.
[Music]
For my heaviness,
for burdens light,
this will be my song.
You are always good.
I'll sing it all day long.
When the day is through
and I am left with you
are all
you are all
good.
[Music]
I set my eyes on perfect faith.
You'll finish what you start in me.
My heart will be an offering.
[Music]
I traded all my fear for peace of mind.
future heaviness
my burdens
lie
and this will be my song.
You are always good.
I'll sing it all day long.
And when the day is through,
I am left with you
are always
you are always
every
meloy
you're singing back to me. You're
singing back
every
meloy.
You're singing back to me. You're
singing back every
meloy.
You're singing back to me. You're
singing back.
Every
me
you're singing back to me. You're
singing back. I traed all my fear for
peace of mind.
You took heaviness
my burdens light
and this will be my song.
You are
good.
I'll sing it all day long.
You are
[Music]
good.
And when the day is through,
I am left with you.
Are all
you
are
good.
Thank you for being a God that we can
trust.
Thank you that you are always with us
that you never leave us or forsake us.
That you pull us up from the miry pit
and set our feet upon a rock.
That you are our firm foundation.
[Music]
You are a good God.
We want to trust you.
We want to listen to your voice, to your
spirit's guidance.
[Music]
We want to live our lives like Jesus
wants us to.
Give us the courage.
Tune us into your spirit, God.
[Music]
May our hearts be sensitive
and our feet quick to follow you.
Thank you.
Thank you for your love. It's in Jesus
name that we ask all these things. Amen.
Would you turn to the person on your
right and your left and say, "The peace
of Christ be with you.
All right,
they're getting that set up. Welcome.
Um, my name is Brett. I'm the pastor
here. And, uh, tonight's it's a special
night. We got something a little bit a
little bit different. No, no sermon.
I would be like maybe a little hurt.
Everyone just erupts standing clapping.
I'm like, "Oh my gosh, I hate it." All
right. Um, but it's we're instead we got
a uh kind of a a little discussion. So
many of you know we've been in this very
long series for at least for us long
like seven weeks. Um titled Re-enchanted
um kind of reclaiming sacred ground in
this kind of secular world. And so, um,
what we're going to do is just kind of
run through a little bit of that series
and just kind of have some unpacking.
So, as we go, I'll give little recaps
and things so that even if you weren't
here for the series, um, you can kind
of, you know, follow along roughly with
what's been uh what's been or being
discussed and what has been discussed in
that past sermon. So, with that in mind,
if we could have
our panelists, our folks come up. Miles,
Val, Landon,
Eden, come on up. Y'all give them a hand
as they come forward.
Any order. Any order. Sit wherever you
want. Yeah.
All right.
So, first off, thank y'all so much for
being a part of this. So where I want to
start, if you could each give just a
quick intro, you know, just a name, a
little bit of background of your own
little just a little bit of your story
so that as you're sharing, folks know,
you know, some of like where how did
this person grow up or what was their
church experience like? Like where how
are you, you know, in essence, what are
you kind of bringing to this
conversation? What's some of the history
and and such? Um I mean, I know that
could be like a 30 minute thing, but you
know, in just kind of a quick way, maybe
we could start down here with Miles and
just work our way over. Yeah. Hi
everyone. Uh, I'm Miles. I grew up um
Church of Christ, which for those who
aren't familiar is a fairly conservative
um Protestant denomination.
Very conservative. Okay. Fairly
fundamental.
My COC crew over here is rating my uh
so um grew up in that context. uh went
to a you know private religious school
where Valerie and I met um and kind of
met and started our relationship within
that context and then
I won't give too much away but but sort
of deconstructed and reconstructed that
together and one of the things I'm
grateful to have gotten to go on that
journey at a similar time with my
partner we've had other friends and
people we've known that that caused a
lot of tension in their relationships
and things like that and um yeah one
thing led to another and now we're
Hi, I'm Valerie or Val. Either one is
totally fine. Um, I'm married to Miles.
We have two girls. Um, Eloise is nine,
Margot is three. Um, I grew up Church of
Christ, which I would say is a fairly
fundamentalist um, group. I would not
have recognized that at the time, but
looking back, I definitely feel that
way.
Um
I um met Miles in college. We went to a
Church of Christ affiliated university.
We got married fairly young. Um and
shortly after we moved to Dallas, we had
been going to a local Church of Christ.
And there were lots of things that just
didn't sit well with us. And we found
our way to um a community called
Storyline, which um unfortunately does
not meet anymore. But it was like a
network of house churches, I would say.
um pretty non-traditional that was been
very formative in my faith. Um for those
of you who speak Inog language, I'm an
Inagram one. Um also I throughout my
adult life have dealt with panic attacks
and depression and I've spent over a
decade in therapy. So that has a very
strong influence on the way I view the
world.
Okay. Um I'm Eden McDonald, pronouns he,
him. Um, I grew up in a
non-denominational church and then, um,
fun fact, the pastor went to prison for
fraud. Um, so, but I didn't know. Um, I
was 12 and I was like, the church ran
out of money. Um, which is what my
parents told me.
But yeah. Um then around the age of
12ish, right before the church stopped
meeting, um I discovered my queer
identity and it kind of transformed
throughout my teenage years. Um and
about three years ago, I found the table
um which has been such a saving grace
for me. Um y'all can pat yourselves on
the back.
Um, no, it's been really great. And I
currently go to college for psychology
at the University of North Texas.
Hi. Uh, I'm Landon Fischer. Um, my wife
Kayle's with with some of the kids over
in the other area. Um, we've also got
two, Charlotte and James. You'll see
them running around being crazy.
Um, I grew up uh in a different kind of
sort of fundamentalist church, a
non-denominational mega church that, you
know, if you peel the sticker off, it's
just Southern Baptist. Um, that's not
too far from here. Um,
but also in a Christian school, at least
for the first, um, you know, five years
of of schooling. Um, a lot of which was,
I think, pretty formative for me and
having a lot of, um,
of an intellectual basis to my faith and
my understanding of what my place in a
church structure was. Um, that set kind
of the groundwork looking back for where
I would end up, which is going to
college at Texas A&M.
um ended up studying philosophy which
was not ironically what kickstarted my
sort of deconstruction but it did end up
fueling it quite a bit. Um but a lot of
things changed quickly for me as I
started questioning some of the
assumptions of what I'd grown up with
both religiously, theologically,
politically all at once in a great big
mix.
um kind of just stuck around nominally
with a church there in college for a
while and felt a little bit out of place
and homeless and then um close to the
end of college, my best friend came out
to me as a trans woman. Um which was
sort of almost a nail in the coffin of I
think I just want nothing to do with
this anymore. Um, and for the last many
years, it was sort of a state of
arrested development of
not still feeling a draw to to certain
things that I found compelling and and
meaningful, but not knowing where to put
all of that. Um, and in the couple of
years before we started coming here last
February, I had started rethinking
through some of those things as our kids
got older and asked more questions.
um things that I had put um on the table
for late on the table uh for later
picked back up and and since we've been
going here it's been I think a a very
healing experience.
Yeah. Yeah. Thank you all. So I think
that gives a good kind of framework for
I I know not everyone here at the table
has versions of those stories. um most
do which is who I was writing this
series for. It was for them and for
those who resonate with that which again
isn't quite everyone. So for some of you
this series is just kind of like this is
just not my thing. what is up with this,
you know, but this this is why because
in essence um here at the table we do
spend a lot of time wrestling with
critiquing the theology the conservative
fundamentalist theology we were many of
us again not all but many of us were
brought up with like 90% of what we do.
However, what I noticed was a kind of
trend as I've been walking with people
now 15 years on this. They're they're
they're often struggling not to ask the
very question that you kind of heard
especially from Landon in particular
really gave it voice but each it's sort
of the subtext of each of your stories
which is why not just leave entirely?
Why why church at all? Why like why
continue? Why why do you need some
progressive space or the like just let
it go and become a kind of you know I
don't know something vaguely secular
person or something. Um so that's that's
the question I was really wanting to
address. So uh to kind of sum it up and
then this will lead into a question.
Most folks who deconstruct Christian
theology um that they were raised in are
very hard on Christianity and Christian
theology in church, right? like that and
that makes sense and rightly so, right?
For but for all the good there, there's
plenty of toxic, you know, Christian
theology and such that needs to be
discarded. However, once they leave the
Christian faith, they're usually
transitioning by default over to a kind
of, you know, western secular capitalist
tradition that they often leave
completely unexamined.
It's almost like they don't realize that
they're not simply leaving Christianity
for no faith at all. They have found a
new one. But this isn't one that they
deconstruct. This isn't one they ask
hard questions about. And it's not just
my deconstructionist friends, you know,
or or folks that would resonate with
your stories. Um, even just my kind of
more progressive Christian friends, it
seems to me, are very naive about kind
of what the actual ramifications are of
no God, no Christ, no big story, no real
ethics to speak of, no real vision of
the good. Hey, you're mostly just a
machine. In fact, really, all of nature
is just a machine. We're kind of
nobody's headed nowhere for no real
purpose. like what does that do to
individuals
um to communities and to political
communities? And I think it's a real um
dead end. So, this series was kind of my
plea to my deconstructing friends, to my
progressive Christian friends to stop
treating the secular with kitty gloves.
Um stop kind of flirting with atheism
and agnosticism unless they really want
to go there, right? That's like I'm not
saying like that's horrible if you do
that. I'm just saying if you really want
to go there, well then go there, but
also you'll have to embrace the
implications of that, right? And and
instead I'm hoping that for folks to see
the kind of beauty of the best of the
Christian faith. So really that's a
summary of the first two weeks of this
series. Um after that it was kind of all
just unpacking the implications in
various domains and such of that. So,
the question would be, do y'all see what
I'm getting at here? Do you resonate
with it? Or are these simply the ravings
of a madman?
Oh, anyone jump in? What? Whatever.
Yeah. Well, I'll start. Um,
I think
that deconstructing your faith, I think
what makes it hard to examine maybe what
else you're picking back up as you're
saying,
I think it's because a lot of people
come to deconstruction from very, very
deep pain. Um, I think there are
horrible wounds that they have
experienced through
their faith, whether that's Christianity
or otherwise.
And
I think part of the reason why it's so
hard to reconstruct is that pain has not
been given
uh it hasn't been borne witness to. Um,
and I don't think it's my job to force
someone through that process,
but I do think it's my job to bear
witness to it. And each person has their
own journey with what they choose to
deconstruct, reconstruct, pick back up.
And that is a process that takes so much
time, so much work. Um, and I I really
do I mean I know for myself that
sometimes
it's easy to
lash out and break down everything that
hurt you because it hurt you so bad,
right?
And it takes so much time to get to a
place to then look at those pieces and
decide,
is any of this good? What do I want to
take from this? And again, I think when
you la when there's an absence of
someone that's saying, "Oh my gosh, I
see you. That wasn't right. What
happened? That was not okay." When you
don't have that, I think it is very,
very hard to move forward.
Oh, um I was just going to say I think
that in Christian spheres and the hurt
that comes from that there is a very
direct line of where the hurt came from
to the person. And I think in agnostic
or atheist cultures where
hurt comes from is not a direct
ramification of or they don't see it as
a direct ramification of the culture.
It's harder to draw the line. So, it's
easier to be mad at God because the line
is so clear, but it gets kind of muddled
in a culture where there's so many other
impacts and so many other things that
draw into the hurt that it's hard to
blame it on one thing or the other
because all of it is just culminating in
one.
Um,
taking it in a slightly different
direction, not to minimize what y'all
said because that was all great. Um, but
as far as like, well, no, I don't think
you're a mad man. Um, as far as like why
why this, why church? Um, I have kind of
like a cynical answer and I have like a
very hopeful one, I think, where the
cynical answer is that like
we're we're so broadly speaking
alienated in our culture that we have no
centers of community like this left
anymore. Like if you look out into the
world, the the closest thing that comes
to like a uh corporate worshipful church
experience is like I don't know, a
sports team, like a professional sports
game. And that's weird. Um so that's
kind of the the cynical answer of what
like for me personally brought me back
to a space like this is like we we miss
that we don't have a community. we don't
have, especially here in Texas, is like
we had values that we wanted to be in a
community with people who shared those
and it was hard to find. Um, so that's
like that's the cynical answer, right?
Very utilitarian, but like a more
hopeful one is that um that there there
there is something different about
uh this this story, right? like there's
something about it that's and that's
kind of what like personally brought me
I think back around to faith is is
precisely how much it doesn't make
sense. Uh which like deep within me I
hate a little bit like it's hard for me
to accept. Uh but like it's it's at its
core um paradoxical
and I think there's something uh
profound about that.
Yeah.
Go ahead. Sure. Uh so my uh my
brother-in-law, my sister's husband is
um from France and some of our
conversations that we've had over the
years is he comes from a very
traditional I would say European
Catholic um sort of background and uh is
sometimes very baffled by some of the
baggage we carry from our American
churches and evangelicism and things
like that. And I remember uh they came
over uh to our house during during COVID
and we were watching a Zoom church
session and and having some conversation
and afterward he he we went for a walk
and he pulled me aside and I'm
translating slightly but he said um who
are the fundamentalists and why are they
so bad?
And I was like, "Oh, well, I meant bad.
I didn't mean bad. I just um" and I
realized from, you know, even that
degree of an outsider, some of our um
the way we were talking about things was
very confusing to him or or just he was
coming from a different perspective.
And, you know, it made me think, you
know, I've heard a child psychologist
say, you know, a lot of times our
teenagers, they um you it feels like
they're against everything that we do.
Um, but it's this first way of finding
their identity of like, okay, mom and
dad are this and so I'm going to be that
and that's how I'm going to first
separate myself of forming my own
identity. And I think at least for me,
my first level and it was probably at
some kind of perhaps teenage maturity
level of establishing my differentiation
was to think about what was before and
okay well I used to believe that and now
I feel this. Um, and and I think that's
a first stage, a natural first stage,
but I think there are are further ones
to come. And Valerie and I have had that
conversation over year over the years
of, you know, she identifies, you know,
the bearing witness to pain and harm.
The complication for me as I've unpacked
some of that is I look a lot like and
represent a lot of the people that were
doing more of the harm um than those
that were receiving that harm. Um, and
that's been tricky for me in my
differentiation and my kind of desire to
maybe push everything out wholesale. Um,
and one of the things I've in recent
years come to to realize I need to
challenge myself more is I've gone
certain a certain distance, but what is
the next step? I've I've disassembled
some things, but what does it look like
to to reassemble um along the way? And I
appreciated this series and helping
that. Yeah, I hear um
kind of a question with the next one,
but it kind of ties in with an answer
y'all have kind of already touched on.
So, it was why do you think most
progressive Christians are um kind of,
you know, not so much why they're tough
on the Christian tradition that makes
sense kind of to the pain and such, but
why so easy on the kind of Western
secular tradition that they're kind of
defaulting into. And I heard interesting
answers. I heard value naming. I think
it's just pain and there's just so much
pain there that it's like they're just
processing what was and and don't really
have the time maybe or energy to to pay
attention to what they're going towards
or something like I kind of you could
clarify and then uh Miles I heard you um
kind of give well giving a little bit
different angle on that. So anyway,
could you all kind of speak to that
question specifically, even though I
know Val, you've kind of touched on it,
but any any other thoughts on and and
specifically I'm thinking too of folks
who have been in this process. I'm
thinking for five 10 plus years. I'm not
at all referring to those who are like
six months out of their church. You're
like, why aren't you moving on so quick,
you know, it's taking forever here? Like
no, no, no. I I'm really thinking of
those who have been at this for maybe,
you know, eight plus years and have just
kind of settled into a kind of vague,
you know, I mean, on sort of all the big
questions. Um, and I wondered your take
on, you know, how that's been for you,
you know, if you found yourself there,
what you've seen others and and how we
might be able to move forward though
while being sensitive, you know what I
mean? not like being jerkish about it
like, "Hey, pull yourself together and
move on, you know, or whatever."
Okay. You sure? Okay. I think um and I
I'm going to try not to make the answer
too political, but you did say Western
capitalism, so that's on you. Um, but I
think for a lot of people it's just
really easy to
um accept what's the easy answer for
everything around you and not examine it
too closely. Um, because as soon as you
start examining something and finding
the cracks in it, you're either
obligated to act to change it or um or
it just tears you apart slowly. Um,
which I think is kind of like where I
was at was being torn apart slowly for
like almost a decade of feeling like I
knew what I I knew what I didn't believe
and knew what I thought I might uh but
not having the energy or the willpower
to actually
um act on any of it. So, um so there's
there's that. Um I think I lost my train
of thought, but that's okay. Someone
else
um Okay. I like this sermon series. One
of the things that I struggle with this
with this sermon series is I feel like
we're trying to put things on a little
bit of a binary. Like you either have
I'll use Christianity because that's
what we're using here. We have
Christianity or we have secular and
almost then we're like kind of setting
up this dichotomy and there's judgments
between those which I really really
don't like. So I'm trying to avoid
falling into that trap. In your
question, I hear this and I you may not
be intending this at all, but I hear
this element of control of someone's
outcome. Like
someone has been deconstructing for over
a decade and they're just not moving on
and they're not really looking closely
at it. And it's like, okay, well that
might be true, but
what is my goal there? Is my goal to
convince them that they need to be over
here or to get them to look critically
at this over here? I I think we have to
be careful when we're I kind of think
when we interact with other people, we
should sort of have this goalless
relationship. Um, so I don't have an
endgame with them. It's not that I don't
care about them. I do. But part of
loving them and showing up and being in
their life is not being like, "And I
need you to get to X." Yeah. Does that
make sense? No, totally. Yeah. Can I
speak to that? Maybe I do. I think I
definitely agree on kind of a onetoone
basis. That would be for sure true. You
know what I mean? Where I would never
like pastorally want to kind of sit with
someone and then be in that mode of kind
of like, oh well, you're on the clock,
you know, something or you know what I
mean? Um, what I'm definitely thinking
of is as a church planter in progressive
spaces, I see this kind of um,
languishing of progressive liberal
churches
and it's slowly killing me. Now, to your
point, that is something I have to just
keep doing business with God on. You
know what I mean? Where I'm kind of
like, oh, but what I see folks kind of
doing is
kind of continually leaving
and and it would be cool. Honestly, what
I wish they would do or what I would
love for them to do would be to find a
new religious tradition or somewhere
where they can find new life. Kind of to
Landon's point, what I see folks
defaulting to is to a kind of, you know,
kind of consumerist
kind of life that I don't necessarily
think is um any it's it's not
necessarily any better for like the
world than what they're leaving. And so
now now again pastorally I'd want to be
careful on a individual you know what I
mean of like just saying that but when
I'm thinking collectively or tren I'm
seeing trends that's kind of where my
mind's going is why are so many folks
who are deconstructing tending to just
leave entirely what's going on you know
what I mean so I don't know if there's a
way maybe to your point that might be a
kind of judginess or something that I
need to just kind of be okay if
progressive liberal churches really do
just all kind of fade away and
you know it's sort of you got your
conservative strands and then you're
kind of more uh you know secular kind of
institutions and such and maybe that is
just the future of something in me
doesn't settle well that you know what I
mean um I don't know so I'm curious as
to how that hits y'all or you know what
I mean yeah I think there needs to be a
place of
progressive Christianity and I think not
a lot of people
understand what that even is and what
that looks like. And so it seems to be
like this is the tradition that I'm from
and it's this Christian conservative
standpoint and I don't like the way that
they do that. And there not a lot of
people know that there's another option
as a progressive Christian. And I've
seen it over and over again talking with
people who are like who are still like I
didn't know you could be gay and
Christian. And like to me it makes so
much sense because it's been such an
integral part of my identity for so
long. But I think just part of it might
just be a lack of awareness that there
is another way to do things. We can
reshape the way that church looks. We
can re-enchant the way that our our
world view around queer people around
minorities
around basically everything the way that
um
traditional um churches have gone. we
can kind of reimagine what that looks
like and a lot of people don't even
know.
I I think within this and I'm Valerie
and I didn't discuss any of this
beforehand. We wanted to approach it
fresh here, but I see so many of the
conversations we had and and she so
often reminds me to be gracious of the
people I'm interacting with and and
understanding everyone on their
journeys. So what I can say at least for
myself as I was going through this
period of deconstruction, what I found
myself uh a bit at risk of was getting
into this kind of um post-modern um
whirlpool of just kind of yelling
everything is relative as I'm just kind
of continuing to spiral and and and
deconstruct. And um for me, one of the
ways I kind of found my way out of out
of that downward spiral a little bit of
of just kind of letting go of everything
was to say, "Okay, here are some
touchstones that are I'm going to accept
as truth and then to start to rebuild my
framework or my worldview um around
those things." And I I noticed a lot of
my, you know, friends or people in my
community going through a similar path
and journey um along the way. And
one of the things that we talked about
in the sermon series that resonated with
me a lot, um, I guess I should mention
my background. I'm a financial planner
and accountant, so I spend a lot of my
work week thinking about finances and
small businesses. I'm a small business
coach and how people can can run their
businesses better. Um, and a book that's
been really impactful for me in that is
Daniel Conorman's Thinking Fast and
Slow, which is kind of one of the same
out of this study of the last 15 years
that's emerged of that our brain kind of
runs in two cycles. We have our our fast
brain that makes decisions. It's
analytical, it's scientific, and we have
our our slower brain that is um it is
feeling, it is perceiving, um, etc. And
um we live in a world that is is
dominated by our fast brains. We make so
many fast decisions and we are so um
flooded with choices throughout our our
daily lives. And if we're not careful to
give space for our slow brain um to
perceive and to to to kind of feel a way
forward um it causes a lot of harm. It
causes people to make poor financial
decisions when they're under stress. Um
it causes I think some of the journey
that we have in deconstruction. And so
that was one thing that just resonated
with me because I've sort of felt it to
be true and observed it to be true um in
myself and in in people that I've, you
know, gotten to know over the years. And
so I think sometimes it's easy to get
into that that fast brain. And that fast
brain is critical. Um and that fast
brain wants to to point out the flaws or
the errors and look for certainty and
things like that. And that that slow
brain um what was what did you call it?
Was it left and right? Um yeah, the two
hemispheres. The two hemispheres. Yeah.
I mean, we're talking about the same
thing with a little bit different terms.
Um, we have to make sure we leave space
for that. Yeah. So, is like some of the
angst then like of like how should
progressive Christians be or some of
that I wonder if that comes from this
fast brain this because there is that
desire for certainty control like
there's some of those things in it. I
don't think it's an entirely bad impulse
to think about. I just I think it's
helpful to kind of poke at why does it
bother so much? No, go ahead. I mean, I
think part of it too is and this is
strictly for this, you know, this
church, but like
and and in this place and this time,
you're you're battling a lot of we live
in like a soup of malaise about the
world that we live in. Like it's and it
I know. Yeah. It's pretty bleak. It's
pretty bleak. It feels pretty bleak all
the time. Uh and and in a lot of ways
feels like it's getting bleaker and that
is heavy on people. Um and that's and
that's for me who's like a straight
white man. So it's just heavy to watch
happen to people I care about. Um so
I think that's part of it. Part of it is
um
is just physical time and distance. Like
like we drive 35 minutes to be here on
Sundays and that's not even that far
compared to some of y'all that I've
talked to that drive almost an hour or
longer. Um and like we do it because we
love being here and we love seeing you
all and we we value that feeling of
community. But even us there's some days
we're like ah we just can't. We just
can't today. like
um and
uh I think it's I think the church is
doing some this church body is doing
something right because we have stuck
around. Um but I can understand why for
a lot of people the weight of all of
that all together becomes too much to to
put the effort up. Yeah. Yeah. I wonder
did y'all have any um well because we
got like I mentioned we had the kind of
two intro weeks and then we kind of went
into like certain areas and we talked
about beauty and creation and sexuality
and um community and relationships and I
um
I oh and politics, you know. So I
wondered was there any any like a
particular one of those weeks or a topic
where you know something that kind of
resonated with you or it challenged you
or made you think in a new way or you
know something along those lines.
Um I
really liked the sermon about community
because I think obviously that's
something we're losing in a secular age.
But I also have seen some trends within
um community and some friendships that I
have where I can see kind of how this is
happening. A lot of people are just
like, "Wow, we're on our phones too
much." Um and like there's there's some
weight to that. But um watching um
people around me and the culture shift
change from we to me has been really
interesting and especially in the
psychology field where a lot of people
are going to therapy and they're
realizing I don't need to carry all the
weight of all the people around me. And
I think that can be very good for some
people. Some people need to hear like
you don't need to carry the burdens of
others. All all it all that really
matters is you and like what you feel
and you need to prioritize you. But I
think
there's always a balance of prioritizing
you and also your community because the
second you
think about yourself too much, you're
now losing your community. And I think
it starts in small acts like the the
phrase you don't owe anyone anything
which is true. Um you don't but like
rides to the airports like
people just Uber now. You don't ask
people around you. You don't have a
community. Um or there's there's several
other examples now that are just
fleeting. Um, but there's a sense of I'm
just I just need to be out for me, which
again can be super freeing for some
individuals. But I think we've skewed so
far to that individualistic mindset that
we don't think how it actually how being
so individualistic ultimately to a
detriment of ourselves.
That's good. Anyone else have anything
to add to that? I I think the the one
about um art in particular resonated
quite a bit with me. Um
if only because it was a lot of
um art that I cared about deeply that I
think kept me, you know, tenuously
hanging on for a long time. Um, and
there's still some others that I I find
I can't necessarily go back to or
certainly can't go back to the same way.
Other songs or books or movies or
whatever it might be. Um, but
I think um, you know, it's in our
nature, in our
our image bearingness of God to be
creators of art. Um, and so when you
were talking about just talking about
that, that that resonated quite a bit
with me is like um finding the ring of
truth in in certain works of art,
whatever they might be.
You have um I was going to say for me
kind of throughout the whole of this
series, one of the things that I kept
coming back to is um well, I guess a
couple of things. um
a reminder of the divinity in all of us,
right? Like a lot of these things that
we talk about, community, sex, politics,
all these different things. I think
sometimes some of the problems come when
we forget that other people are God's
creation, like every single person. Um,
and
another thing that I think goes along
with that is then in thinking of like an
ethic about how you live your life is
um, this is comes from one of our
friends from our old church. He used to
say, "What is the next thing love
requires of me?" Um, and I really love
that framework too for approaching
things. Um, and I think one thing that
helps with these, um, is slowing down.
Um,
which is hard. Um, one thing I actually
do in communion, um, that helps me
connect with both the humanity and the
divinity of the people around me is, uh,
when I'm given the bread and the, um,
the cup, um, and someone says, you know,
Christ's body broken for you, I say,
thanks be to God, and I make sure I look
in the eye of the person giving it to
me. like how beautiful that there is
this other image bearer of God that is
sharing this with me. It's so small but
it's slow and it and it reminds us of
the beauty in all of those small small
moments. Um so that's that's a lot of
what I took away from throughout the
whole series.
And I was going to second I really
resonated with the community uh one that
was actually a Sunday that we were not
here and so I didn't hear it until I
went back and listened to the podcast
getting ready for tonight and there was
so much I resonated with and the thing
that kept coming to mind for me is like
as a society and in a culture we have
many wonderful things that has brought
us but for example we have like foods
with this incredible like caloric
density now you know we have crispy
cream and and processed foods and all
these things and some of them are
wonderful Um but if we are not conscious
of how we consume them, it will harm our
bodies. And I think in a similar way,
our society presents us opportunities
for loneliness. Um and if we're not
conscious of that, it will harm our
bodies. Um it's kind of the easy
calories to get to loneliness. So many
of these things whether it's um for many
people it could be working from home and
and realizing that they go you know a
40-hour week without interacting with
anyone and then if they don't go out in
the evenings or don't have community on
the weekends you know not that there's
anything wrong with any one thing but an
unexamined life around that can be um
causing tremendous amounts of loneliness
and so I love uh Brett I I wrote it down
the way you you worded it um in the
podcast there um that from John 12:13 as
a definition for friendship that greater
love has no one than this, to lay down
one's life for one's friends. Who are
your friends? We'll just ask who are you
currently laying your life down for? Um,
I thought that was just like such a
beautiful imagery. Um, because I think
there's so many things like having
community is hard, right? You got to
like get in your car. If you have kids,
pack up your kids. If you're going to
see friends, you got to like get a
babysitter or, you know, clean the
kitchen later so you can go whatever the
thing is. Like there's there's barriers
to it. And I think we live in a culture
that teaches us that's folly. Like it's
not advancing your career or getting
your chores done or like like what's the
again the fast brain kind of answer of
just like checking off your to-do list.
Um and it could be perceived to just
wasting an afternoon with an old friend
or something like that. Um but I think
this message of love, love for
ourselves, love for our community calls
us in a different direction. Um, and for
me it it brought to mind I I jotted it
down as well the story of the woman um
pouring perfume on Jesus's feet and how
in her culture uh that was that was
total folly like wasting this valuable
thing on someone's feet. Um but for her
it was laying her her her life down to
display her love and I think we have
that opportunity to give that perfume to
people in our community.
I just something that came to mind when
I was uh listening to it too was um I
watched a video of somebody who said
everyone wants a village but doesn't
want to be a villager
and that's what reminded me of everybody
wants the easy answer of not having to
do the hard thing for a friend or give
the kid a ride or you know whatever but
then you're not creating. You're not
planting the seeds to be able to become
a village to become a community full of
love and life. And so
it's beautifully said. Well, thank you
all. Thank you for sharing. Can you all
give them a hand?
[Applause]
So good. They got some wisdom.
So, um, I'm going to go ahead and
transition to communion. So, on the
night that Jesus was betrayed, he had
one final meal with his disciples. And
at that meal, he held up a loaf of bread
and he broke it. And he said, "Take it
and eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." And then he held up a cup of
wine. He said, "Take it and drink. This
is my blood shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me." And so, as we come
forward, we that's what we're
participating in. we're we're one body
uh with Christ and connecting uh again
with each other and and with him. So the
way we'll go about communion is we'll
just go rowby row. We'll start here at
the front and uh just form one line here
in the middle and as one row finishes,
the next can go ahead and join in the
line. We practice what's called an open
table. So if you're here tonight, you
want to participate, then you're free to
do that regardless of your, you know,
exact denomination or uh religious, you
know, beliefs or theology. If you want
to connect with Christ, then uh you you
come forward and do it. And having said
that, also no pressure if you're not in
a place you want to do that, that's
perfectly fine, too. You should know the
red is wine, the white is grape juice.
And uh finally, you can just partake
whenever, however you'd like. Some folks
like to take immediately, some like to
come and kneel here at the front or
return to their seats, but no one will
lead you through the exact, you know,
moment of partaking. So this is the
table, not of the church,
but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more. So come you who have much faith
and you who have little. You who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long. You who have tried to
follow and you who have failed. Come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
Come all greedy.
Come all liars,
come all shame,
come all wealthy, come receive it to the
table. Come today.
Come all broken.
Come all needy.
Come all poor.
Come all slaves.
Come all rulers. Come be seated.
Come all sinners. Come all saints. Come
to the table
from near and far.
Come from the shadows.
Come out of the dark.
[Music]
There's room at the table.
We saved you a seat.
Come to the bquet.
Come join in the feast.
Will you guys stand with us? Every race,
every nation,
come all rebels,
come all gang.
From the fringes,
come to Jesus.
To a table full of grace.
To the table.
Come and stay. Come to the table.
Come eat and drink.
There's no inner circle.
Come dine with the king.
Recline at the table.
Come let down your guard.
You're never a strangeanger.
Just come as you are.
Come behold.
[Music]
Come be loved.
Come accept it.
Come now go.
Come behold.
Come be love.
Come accepted.
Come now come.
Prepared is the table.
We're ready to feast.
The party is waiting.
There's more still to feed.
The harvest is ready.
Go fill every sea.
Go live out the mission
as a kingdom of priest
[Music]
and go live out the mission
as a kingdom of priest.
Oh, thank you all so much for joining us
this evening. If uh you're new, we'd
love for you to fill out a card at the
little table on the way out the door, or
you can scan the QR code and fill out an
online visitor card.
The way that we get more relationship
and more support and spiritual
connection is through our meetups. If
you are not yet part of a meetup, please
scan the QR code and find one that will
work for you. There's lots of them,
different days and times.
Uh ministry teams, if you are call the
table your home, but you're not
currently serving on a ministry team,
we'd love to have you give it a try. Uh
we have teams for tech, the guys in the
back. We have the kids ministry and
hosts are currently in need of you. So,
fill out the QR code or the little card
over there as you go out the door.
Generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration, praise, and worship. If the
table is your home and you would like to
join us financially, then scan the QR
code or visit the tabletx.org.
[Music]
Now, I'd love to send you out with this
blessing.
You can hold out your hands to receive
or you can just open up your hearts for
these words.
You are a child of God.
You You are a child of God. This is true
on your best day and it is true on your
worst day. And so as you go into your
week ahead with all of its highs and
lows and everything in between, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved, that you are worthy, and that you
are accepted just as you are. and go
filled with the God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact with. Be
blessed and we'll see you next Sunday.
[Music]
Where are you going?